[Music]
it's morphin time put what they do more
fur in the screen and let everyone know
it's time to transform into a real
winner who is your favorite pie right
there uh
I like I like Billy in the original
series uh I feel like I feel cuz
everyone was like I love the Green
Ranger I loved but the Green Ranger
wasn't really the same person which was
the real joke on everyone in the other
eye was definitely definitely more of a
blue Ranger guy cool so we are checking
out Power Rangers battle for the grid
yeah last week the second I believe on
most platforms it's $20 which is not bad
yes oh good it's a pretty cool fighting
game if you like Power Rangers Go Go
Power Rangers is correct yeah yeah
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers all right
here's the best see we're already going
for it it's it's it's the white is all
about black Ranger alright yeah he's
real interesting in this slit they did a
whole buncha like this isn't the Power
Rangers that I know these are like all
the extra ones that came out after - so
how do you want to do this we could what
is the arcade just story story run
through yeah you got all of these look
at the got a gun mastodon century I
don't remember any of the power rangers
having guns play a little pistol but not
like like an automatic like space rifle
hey you know that I fell off when I when
I stopped watching this fine but yeah I
like how they're just straight up their
names Joe Oliver Jason Leigh's good
little those sorta Drakon oh yeah we
could do like an arcade run first let's
see that or warm up who do we want to
take through it what you know you can
play whoever you want cuz I'll end up
fighting you and I will pick the Green
Ranger and use my flute to call upon the
dragon Zord well I was having a pretty
good time with the Ranger Slayer
no to play other Power Rangers I hope
not
oh yeah you get to pick three people uh
let's take our Green Ranger with us and
you know what let's take a little
Mastodon sense yeah you get to pick a an
assist dragon Zord yeah I can call him
in anyway because I have the Green
Ranger though all right flank a cold R
then yeah I'm gonna go with the dino
burgers now you do whatever you want
that's that's the best Jam chapter one
do you get to do like the mega dragon
Zord so his his super move calls in like
the finger missiles and then you
actually get to like docked I do call
them in separately but apparently you
have plans to expand the roster out and
add more time see the path and stuff
like that yeah you want Ninja Storm also
my favorite I like to ninja storm I
played a lot of the ninja storms listen
this is the current roster to stand
Nathan but as we mentioned there is
gonna be like DLC and stuff of that so
season pass so I think you can get the
season pass like the full the game and
the season pass for 40 30 90 minutes oh
we're gonna have a heck of a time later
huh oh yeah look at that
your Hawkeye you can do a little box
yeah yeah yeah traps man I'm gonna get
ran up later I haven't touched this game
oh what's that
I accidentally activated one of my
special moves yeah yeah yeah you're
telling me that it's just one button
input
oh so it's there are no like actual like
core circles or anything like that okay
so like if you want to do any of your
special moves you have pressed forward
or backward on a move so like so this
button is just special okay and it lets
you kind of like you can do backward
it's Oh Lord it does a different one I
never saw you shoot five arrows and then
arrow right oh good all the people to
help me out peace swap out yeah okay
so I think you just ho look at that look
at your little beam rifle yes that's a
bit bigger than I thought it was dude
that's like that shot right yeah I was
gonna say he's got mines shots
oh this okay at least you have to reload
they took that into consideration he
doesn't even want to run oh there you go
yeck shoulder tackle and they're like uh
he's got a golf's all the time with
Tommy leading getting it done though the
gun golf swing is very good oh you can't
get in you just can't get in this is
like the best Ranger right here that I
think it's the right Ranger
we're in that's why he's called the
mastodon century oh my good night this
guy might be calling it in novio Oh
Perry actually went for it okay wound
Shino Jitsu Naruto no there there's a
lot crime says EDF is better that's a
lot we're learning about this oh he just
disappears when it's over the characters
are not going art wait the characters
are going to be locked
okay behind you'll see yeah I make that
mix yeah I guess most fighting games
nowadays I feel like Locke most of their
new like fighters and stuff behind DLC
sadly I think the $40 version comes with
the season pass yeah within one that's
$40 for the season pass doesn't oh yes
uh at least you don't you won't mistake
you
Zordon he's like a ghost some sort okay
oh okay phase out of existence real
quick oh yeah links now a little mine
you can't get in the AI you should have
probably put on hard or something you're
probably Judith it's okay we're just
showing off the arcade trying to do that
so I think it's a revenge mechanic so I
have to get hit to do it okay
that's alright dispatch of this man
did your super take the whole bar I
think should do one of these awesome
shoot the ground okay so Hawkeye is
level three though he shoots the ground
and then ant-man comes out oh oh yeah
here we go here we go this this is my
boy right here get him Tommy he's in it
he's moving his super better be playing
the there it is okay good yes I'll
remember it oh and you kick a link off
of it
oh the dragons are our best best best
bot best bottleneck best Metal Gear
well they ahead Chuck Norris is the best
Ranger no no no dragon Zord FTW hell
yeah oh that that special only uses up
one bar it used to okay up say you did
it and shoot that nothing happened
oh we got it's not a watcher combos we
are that's that's evolving which is not
good for me no it's fine
this is the practice that I need I'm to
fight sorry I haven't touched the game
no I'm still up put my sword on door
done it's like a little he he looks like
he's not having a good time
well he is a face stuck in a tube it's
very true telling you hot info dropping
the knowledge you're the the grandpa's
could be a bit better and the game could
be maybe a little bit more tuned but
it's it's not bad I think it's so far
from what I've seen it's pretty
competent before like the price you're
paying for the people that always
complain about $60 games you know I mean
this is also on switch this is like this
feels like it's like an Xbox Live Arcade
game and that's what it's priced as
you never know there's some Power Ranger
fans out there man yeah and I watch that
know the latest movie but I heard it's
actually not bad oh okay
stuffed it she's using like one frame
jabs or something
Oh starters it's got some some cloth
techniques Oh God
Oh too short little rash I'm just trying
to combo into like a cyst source of
Earth's watch right there but let me let
me in right in front of his face
disrespect get rocketed finger missiles
it's it works I've been able to call in
the Megazord yet which oh you will later
when you oh here we go that's it that's
it we got six hit combos I'm so in
trouble later y'all know you're gonna be
fine you're gonna be like ah this is
this is easy everything's just gonna be
super free she playing like total [ __ ]
out right now yeah blue oh you guys
think that Power Rangers deserve
action-adventure game I hope I don't you
think that the the Power Rangers deserve
an action-adventure game versus this I
don't know this is what they chose oh oh
heck yeah nailed it Oh Yellow Ranger she
got like a blade and a gun yeah that's
uh oh looks like oh I'm gonna have to
play her Blake from a cross tag with
that set up like a pirate yeah
there you go just one line that slash
and its support for players in local no
this is a it'd be kind of cool of it did
play versus will see a real bat out now
you want I mean like I'll do more than
what the what the Peters doing but I'm
definitely not gonna like be that much
better
they came should be for you to play I
don't know how they would make money
ever it's not like apex or something or
fortnight where they have things that
you would actually want to buy here
here's what you could do you could take
every character and give them a Mighty
Morphin skin as a thing you'd have to
buy like the different variations of a
skin yeah and then that would probably
give her an iteration of a power injury
rather yeah now they're they're starting
to show up Oh they've waken up oh we got
yep
that's a good assist man out oh he's
mastered our sentry just to get that
assist he's like a zoning character uh
this does come out brick we're aren't
pulling on xbox right now yes it's out
on xbox and it's switch oh it's uh oh no
it's just switching Xbox one PlayStation
4 on April 2 it was Xbox one and switch
on the 26 of mark yeah and then the PC
version I think is a little bit later
who I don't know
for PC I also think the game supposed to
be cross-platform with everything flat
PlayStation that's a Metacritic score of
62 it's not terrible that'd be
considered fine oh this that's we're
gonna mix ups yeah yeah Oh taking out
our evil twin there we go happy birthday
all Pickler birthday he shouldn't have
stayed out as long as he did
that was I'm back oh it didn't care I
couldn't kill him you're the best friend
that's fine you just call it out all
right why don't you just get out of this
yes let's just fight all right I'm tired
of you getting practice I need press
it's gonna say it there's gonna be a
certain point we're just gonna be like
practice I didn't even look at where our
I'm assuming the picture-in-picture
spine where is that just the top PC
layer in the summer I gotcha thank you
Xbox vs points what you have it's on all
platforms now tickets versus there is a
move list I don't know if we need it
though
speak for yourself I I think they all
have the same inputs got it got a run
Tommy you know Oh green V 2 V 2 try some
characters I haven't played with yet
that's a real gross color for gold are I
don't know where that Oh cuz it's locked
yeah you do have to buy some of these
with the season pass or something yeah
we got it rock the mastodon and then yo
whoa it's a white ranger and black angry
oh yeah take your drink double dragons
they left it for you so is it really
just one button its vessel this is light
medium but it sometimes it's like ranged
if your characters range objects and
then that's like you're heavy okay Oh
anime fighter and then forward and
backward do your special moves for that
and then this is your actual special
moves
okay no problem I figured yeah it's not
like it go there oh yeah I got nothing
oh yeah look my team was stacked
okay we got we got some range of got it
some going hey that's a button I lied
y'all we're as bad as the PPV
oh there we go that's pretty alright
okay oh we got mix-ups oh ho ho oh no
don't be an anti-air everything went
dark and nothing hit no oh oh yeah dive
dive a kick
oh hey oh oh good you are you can hikes
there we go you got your own don't be
dead
no wood outta here with that and then
switch yeah bring out my big angry bird
boy have a bomb oh oh god under you
super I'm not gonna do it oh it's a
parody oh you do a level three or did
you I I think I might be just how much
super mean right Oh swap the flip and
snapback get put yourself in the corner
oh no bomb tech I have a bomb
I'm alright
there's no air - and I think that's the
thing that's throwing me off the most
oh oh
megazor what did I do oh my lord
the the sword comes in oh yeah oh yeah
that's cheap
no that's fun that's fine oh no oh man
oh I feel like there might already be
like a tier list for this video game and
I think I might hope he I might know who
would be in certain spots I feel like I
know us already I'm already tapped into
it yeah do you think Green Ranger is up
there what he might be up there I
figured you out 40 but downloaded and it
was only the first match that's a button
Eric in 2019 yeah alright and you can't
be a ranger best Ranger and everyone
knows it
I kind of like the Lord here I'm gonna
play I'm gonna play some big some big
boy nope gonna play some oh that is a
gross color but we're gonna go with it
I'm going with all the alternate colors
here I kind of kind of like this
character a bit actually shocked there
isn't more um bad guys yeah right you
know who do i pair with the two bad guys
I'm a mastodon century
something is ragging shield version of
The Mighty Morphin Power Rangers Red
Ranger I got a dude I gotta have one
gonna sit no that's fine
mega colgar I wonder what he's gonna do
oh is it just was this not random is it
just the training room I guess well
because we're gonna training room again
all right training room it's okay this
is where you can see the best so you're
having fun I can't tell the game looks
it's it's one of those games I could
have fun for like yeah half an hour hour
like just because I have nostalgia
preparing I'm having a good time playing
it but I'm definitely reminding myself
that this is a $20 key so slow oh he's
not that slow I lied he's got some some
quick things okay oh she can like go go
out and back in oh oh - okay
oh I don't know what tornado move I just
did but that was cool
this is not where I want to be that's
not what I wanted what the head like
armored move oh yeah you want to keep
them in here Oh Mike's I got two machine
gun boys Oh what is that I'm okay with
all this hi guys good oh you betcha oh
my god I need some Megazord yes clearly
oh oh oh oh yeah no this guy's my it's
just only character how do I call him
[ __ ] gold are both bumpers that's not
it
there you go yeah you're trouble now oh
it's the same thing he also has a sword
Oh God
ah he's got the uh what you McCall move
that janma Oh off the ground okay look
look
what's my overhead yeah I got you in the
shadows round I was doing phased out
oh man fan of this bringing in like the
big yeah I don't know if it seems like I
feel like there's like oh we need to
have a comeback mechanic what do we do
uh
Megazords we don't use them yeah I wanna
go with this guy again cuz he's he's got
some cool Lord darken yeah yet the big
plays
I don't played is the Magna defender
yeah Morgan both the all-lady team here
alright we still haven't called the
Dragon Sword in so I'll have to see what
that is dragons or doesn't have a sword
so hopefully it's like rockets or
something just Rockets yeah here I'll do
those same things I can if I get one so
we haven't picking random it's just been
always giving us the missing sage forest
is there story mode no there's just
arcade and vs. and some training things
it's fairly fairly bare bones but again
it's $20 yeah I know sorry that base
which seems like a missed opportunity
because it's Power Rangers we're a bulk
and skull it's a good question
hopefully you next ELC I like her a lot
figure out though
you give this guy yeah okay huh Oh No
is that Oh
yeah oh happy birthday I'm just gonna
attack ah whoo that's a wall again go oh
that was good smart thank you
oh I got dated this this is uh this is a
heck of a setup you have anti-air you've
got a straight shot you've got something
to put down in front of you oh there's
the drill god oh my god
dead I'm on the other side oh happy
birthday
Oh God Oh No ha ha into the mind okay
all right dude the yellow range gia
Morgan Street hood all these characters
feel free legit Goldar was okay it's a
big boy
yeah I'm not I'm not swinging I like the
you can kind of feel the influences on
some of the characters like Pink Ranger
plays like Yukari and persona ultimax
you got Blake fur for the Yellow Ranger
MMPR red I like dragon Zord little drill
yeah a drill in there yeah
dragon Rana says I almost feel feel like
this was rushed a bit to release before
I'm Caleb and I like it but it feels
like it could have been better and more
polished in some areas yeah I mean it's
tough you can I don't think you can
compare this to Mk I don't think that's
fair yeah not only from like a price
perspective but just for my development
perspective to like you know nether
realms were making fighting is for a
long time as well so I don't know I'm
having fun and I'm a pretty good time
but I'm also very excited for Mortal
Kombat
that is not good
I'm still trying to like find like
launchers and stuff it's not it's not
paying off all the time dad Oh No do it
do it that's fine this is fine oh this
guy's scary oh that's like a setup
oh yeah getting mauled Oh
oh I had a thing I'm dead so dead
turbo dead
oh god it is tail just dropping in all
my life is gone come back and kind of
great I guess so yeah Megazord ready
dude I don't know I'm turbo dead
I died in Megazord I didn't even get the
chance to see how I want to run that
back yeah oh yeah and I want to run that
back okay Green Rangers fun to play - I
don't know who who he reminds me most of
but he's got a he's got was made by
anyway games the lack of an air dashes
is really the thing that's I think doing
the end cuz this wants to play like it's
an anime fighter but it's missing the
air -
yep oh I don't know what to do after
that oh she's got push blocks to just
never mention that I guess Oh what am i
doing I could just get some missiles out
of them oh boy
that's it I don't know what it does oh
boy how far does this go far enough to
switch
I love it I love it so much
oh boy oh boy
[Music]
not good
what heck yeah
oh my lord I'm dead whoa all right you
know what it's okay
megazord okay good luck with this oh my
huh
that's okay you probably get hit as it's
like happening oh boy oh my god Samba
Highness okay that diet that mechanic
needs enough yeah I'm not feeling that
it like disrupt so many things I'd
rather have like an x-factor or
something as a comeback mechanic it was
really cool though I like you can call
it a Megazord yeah but but it is it's so
cheap it like I need I always gonna beat
you because I had it on deck you're a
half life I had full life unless you
totally like outs killed me yeah it's
it's a weird it's a it's a very powerful
comeback we can make this mr. Drakon
again hi guys
thought third person kind of adventure
looks hey I'm glad you you either way II
am Morgan is doing work for me so and I
don't think I was playing the Pink
Ranger that wall the ranged wing Jack
I'm still about the Dragons word I have
to oh I didn't know that I could call on
its foot and just stomp everything yeah
all right
no Zordon does not talk
it's kind of weird that there's no vo oh
there's one
come on No
do it Oh No oh happy birthday so sneaky
do it to it
Oh yikes oh my goodness that was so much
I'm blocking there oh no we got feet
here too all the gun seems fair
definitely totally fair totally knocked
you out of your super that probably
would have killed me
all right I'm just gonna watch him kill
you oh boy do you have to actually do
something maybe oh you do you have to be
like attacking yeah like that and they
huh
I basically I'm just gonna save that
till after he uses it so then I have
mine which is really stupid but whatever
you know maybe that's strength I guess I
don't know or maybe you use it early and
then you do it again I think when you
use it it's gone oh you like you can
never do it again yeah start off with
the Magna defender and I haven't used
Tom you know where else been using Gaea
too much mix it up yeah yeah never not
gonna pick the dragon Zord is pretty
cool but the Megazord
need more characters yeah it's weird
it's where that there aren't more I
don't know I think the the trying to
rush there they are gonna have a story
mode hold eventually later plan for
later release that's good
so they're the creators of the boom
studios tire in your comic book
cross myself up oh my goodness
I pressed the button oh but you're still
good oh I found my gun you gotta like
yeah like tease it out was just kind of
weird for a projectile but hey you know
I didn't follow you up at all shoot oh
that was real nice
yeah yeah oh that's so dirty I love it
dududu jump all right no supers hit for
a lot less
oh okay No ah it is it just finish you
off like that oh my xbox yeah yeah I
just shoot out I'm like Jubilee I just
shoot out a bunch of fireworks I guess
there's a lot of like presentation fur
for just shooting out a bunch of
fireworks I'm very into her again I'm
not feeling the magnet defender
yeah he's slow he's kind of awkward for
me I gotta go back to Gaea more
it's got a 62 actually Metacritic RV RV
swathi
thank you guys and gals all for tuning
in to guess Wildlife ooh Lord Dragon's
throne
we are live Monday Friday 11:00 a.m.
usually for 90 minutes we'll probably
gonna be 60 minute one yes you know
we've shown you all the characters we're
kind of just playing for the sake of
playing at this point there's some
combos you're trying to get stylish oh
yeah Oh kicks
oh no I yeah I'm dead now no this is
your best character I gotta get rid of
them I don't know how to deal with them
this so threatening
my anti-air shot how did it feel
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the golf
swing low oh I get it now okay
ah
yeah hittin got a lot of work to do
though yeah yeah
oh so like I don't know how you were
still alive oh no the corner oh I'm
learning I'm learning my thing a little
bit a little bad time
ooh complete a scrolls uh uh graphics
look like it's a switch game it's on the
switch joke's on you ha ha uh no I want
over on this one back yeah that's good
one
I really wish there's a little bit of
video or something something I got my I
got Wolverine right here that's that's a
really good character to say she's kind
of like
Oh No
just some some like good invincibility
when you hit that ex2 I think
whereas to this oh stop it and have it
mess up I botched it
No get off that wall yeah
I think this is the only time I've
actually kind of felt like I needed the
comeback when I called it in like I'm in
a real bad spot
yeah oh it shoots low dang hey I'm
liking me who Wolverine
yikes Wolvie White Ranger is always the
best ranger
well he's not white Rangers not in the
game you have to play as the Green
Ranger
yeah which is there is there no there
isn't a skin that turns him into the
White Ranger not yet at least
Jason Lee Scott don't pick draggin him
this disgusting gold are you do that
who is this for it looks like a team
game of power in juicers for kids I
don't know there's people like myself
that have nostalgia for firing Jews grew
up watching fire engines I don't know if
I died kind of stick powers into being a
thing that's just for kids yeah
it's what the cartoons are for though
yeah it's real gross I'm here and I'm
angry fight me on my space station Green
Ranger
I just breathe on you I think
I know if I could be mauled by her it's
it's right that's overkill there's no
escape
Swiss cheese get it out of here
one more time okay that wasn't too bad
yes oh geez I want to run back I don't
know how I fight through that though
yeah it's as soon as you get open it's
just a guaranteed like forty percent any
hit it feels like it's that big I forgot
I had gold are not as good as racking as
you are he's going he's got some weird
weird things but he's pretty cool as
much as I been touting greenery I got a
big oh excuse me
well there you go heck yeah whoa what do
it again do it again it feels like the
the like vocal stuff is just really
subdued or something maybe maybe we'll
hit oh heck yeah Rex
it's frickin launcher so short-range
come on Green Ranger come on come on
come on yeah wow the damage Oh Oh grab
is a launcher oh man oh yes yeah I think
you just get hit by like everything so
you've come to fight me Red Ranger
oh we all know who the best is mr. red
it's the Megazord that's who he would
resort to these tactics Red Ranger fight
for my friends oh boy
yikes I wish that I knew what it was
like to play a Red Ranger because
anytime I get stuck with him I get to
just calling my Megazord not funny he
has slow some slow moves so like I
couldn't just like jab my way out of
like dealing with minx because I feel
like she's too fast
almost oh she has the okay minx is
really good though she's like super fast
yeah yeah I refuse I will not call him
in you not do it yeah I don't wanna do
want to do it not do want a gentleman's
rule I'm like I don't knock I'm just not
gonna do it because I know I just can't
I just can't
I'm like watering it and I'm like I
can't I won't call it in either okay so
we'll do straight a straight fight okay
cause last time I I'm like I just have
to hold block because I don't know when
this tax come again and even when like
you do hold block it still does a like a
ton of chip damage all the purple huh
fits pretty good mm-hmm
I'm hawkeye oh heck yeah AHA Kia haha
oh no I didn't get better at calling it
assists that that may be my thing yeah
yeah why that guys still out Oh
charge up yeah you like her neutral
special lets her get a stronger arrow
again I'm going to bring slow boy in Oh
No just turn sure I'm over right and so
oh no it's very tall Oh
follow it up he's just a slow boy you've
got a big armored heavy set of armor on
oh yeah
that's a lot of damage
I didn't mean that I'll take it I guess
I'm down I got range all right oh joy oh
that's that's very good the fact is that
it's all character he's as by far your
best characters he's got he's got some
good good tricks tonight on I couldn't
figure him out I feel like that was much
better because we didn't call in the
Megazord I told you it feels like a like
a fair fight when I was like Oh megazor
is coming in I'm so screwed
I like can't block I can't do anything
you want to run a poker people all right
all right so I gotta figure out this
this girls so far my favorites are minx
is now higher up for me she's very fun
and then tia is a gia Morgan that Yellow
Ranger yeah oh no why I -
happy birthday that was a lot of a lot
of hits for one button press so I got to
get it off and knocked down or something
lose it and then lose it immediately and
I died oh yeah he just his - go straight
into a run which I don't think other
characters do we just we just let me
Josh oh boy
he's got some pretty cool oh no that's
wait that's way too much that's some
like Dante nonsense he'll break every
night you know then back out of the air
Oh
helen breaker oh no no no it's gonna
chip me out I don't think there is a
chip kill yeah okay yeah oh my goodness
I found a new bread and butter huh
butter into e^x it's a big big damage
yeah yeah yeah I need to send this boy
out sooner I don't want him to I don't
know I think he does big damage but man
that's not a good anchor I'm really
surprised that there aren't like you
know like the classic arrangers like
jams going I just thought about that
what I didn't even I haven't pressed the
red Rangers button until now what the
heck is wrong with me stylish we we just
run right in front of that bomb really
quick
okay okay
those don't hit on the ground this does
though this that hits a lot like God
yikes okay maybe low you're just too
shot me with your shotgun I think I got
my team now you're curious Oh apparently
Justin won't helped me yeah yeah Justin
long and I think clockwork - oh wow I
got my team now I know who I would pick
actually I don't even know Gio Morgan's
the best assist I need to learn how to
assist I need I mean it's the only thing
I don't do
all right last best-of-three yeah I'm
down unless you want a different quad no
I'm good all right I've been feeling
these these guys the most I think all
right put your fake fight money in your
your buy some salty bucks
give me a salty Power Ranger books your
Rita bucks there you go after 10,000
years
aha okay
we get them mess them up
that's mistake that's gonna hurt that
hurt that hurts a lot oh yeah get it get
it yeah
there's a lot of you forcing me to swap
here oh yeah I think it's a counter I
haven't gotten it to work
yeah that definitely is okay thank you
okay oh yeah
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
I didn't you
I'm gonna hit you oh there's like some
iframes on the snapshot yeah
oh alright alright one zero one zero
that's always - no it's that that got
spicier than I wanted it to get drink
I'm hungry yeah oh man
run it back do it again
I think the train station would have the
best music
Oh No
she's so fast
yeah this going a little bit earlier
fill yet a lot of supinator in this game
too
yikes Oh No
oh no oh yeah too high up yeah
whoof before you even hit the ground I'm
already playing my my dagger flu should
be using that more often should you
think that more often
I don't know how I'm gonna make this
work that hurt a lot
oh boy that's that's a lot of [ __ ]
though I don't think you can't die to
fifth oh yes so a lot of damage though
yeah Wow and there you have it that's it
yeah that's that's the end of power
interests the end of Power Rangers
thank you Ben thank you it's fun yeah
check it out if you want to it's out
came out for most part for I think every
platform is a PC which we don't know
when that is but yeah check it out 1999
if you want if you want the season pass
comboed it's like $39.99 I think
eventually it sounds like they're gonna
have story so you know maybe check that
out down the road I'm still not a fan of
the whole like I felt like I'd rather
have a 3d fighter like that then the old
dragon Zord Megazord make a gold are
definitely I yeah I'm not a huge fan
that but yeah whatever any thoughts uh
more funny I thought it would be a
pretty good time playing it anyways
thank you all for tuning in come back
tomorrow we'll be back
lemon a.m. I thought I had a game but
then that's xp for Thursday so we'll see
figure it out till then bye bye bye
[Music]